one guy used to be a senior banker in
Zimbabwe but when the coup happened
three years ago her connections put her
life at risk she was forced to flee the
country with her children and claimed
asylum in England she now lives in a
small flat isn't allowed to work and is
provided with the equivalents of 43
dollars a week to feed and clothe
herself and her kids that money is not
enough to buy clothes it's not enough -
it can be math maybe to buy food but
it's also difficult for you to meet
other needs like buying clothes it's
difficult for for for for us to top up
it's difficult for us - to pay for
Internet you need to choose when guys
experiences are the norm for asylum
seekers in Britain recently we met up
with Binney an Eritrean who delivers
food to refugees in the northern town of
Middlesbrough he told us he'd found a
woman who hadn't eaten for 17 days and
was on the point of starving to death
when you are over the age of 70 you have
been confined into a 4x4 metres world
sharing a house with another three
people from different cultures and
nationalities on top of that you have
got arthritis health conditions diabetes
and also some things you need someone to
talk to you because that have a great
impact in turn mental health opposition
politicians have been pressing the
government to increase the weekly amount
of money asylum seekers get during the
lockdown and last week there was a rise
of the equivalent of about $3 a week the
government justified it on the ground
that it's above the inflation rate
though in reality it barely makes a
difference many people now happen to
wait for several months if not years for
a decision on their asylum application
and so you'd be living on what is now 39
pounds 60 a week for a long time and the
impact of that over time and just how
hard it can be for people not to be able
to save up to afford to buy clothes for
the the winter or to replace basic
cooking utensils really adds up over
time and we don't think that something
which the government has ever really
taken into consideration asylum seekers
aren't alone the government recently did
a u-turn over the provision of food to
children from the poorest families in
the country
whose parents have told us they had to
choose routinely between feeding their
children or feeding themselves since all
this began the Johnson administration
has made a great deal out of being able
to magic up hundreds of billions to give
to workers who cannot do their jobs
effectively paying them to stay at home
the total costs of giving asylum seekers
some money for a few basic necessities
is by comparison very small indeed but
clearly these things are not about
morality but about political will
Lawrence Lee Al Jazira Downing Street in
London